el círculo es quizás la figura más
fundamental en el universo el círculo
aparece en órbitas de planetas aparecen
las llantas e incluso aparece a nivel
molecular así que parece ser que vale la
pena platicar acerca de él y entender
algunas de sus propiedades déjame
empezar con lo siguiente para empezar
los puntos en la orilla de un círculo
siempre son equidistantes a un punto
dado que es el centro del círculo lo voy
a marcar por acá que es este centro de
acá es decir cada uno de estos puntos
está a la misma distancia de este punto
que marque en color rosa si esto de acá
afuera a tres centímetros por decir algo
entonces estoy acá también sería tres
centímetros y estoy acá también sería
tres centímetros vale todo todos éstos
están exactamente a la misma distancia y
esa distancia especial a la cual siempre
están se le conoce como radio entonces
la distancia de cualquier punto de la
orilla al centro se conoce como radio
voy a poner déjame ponerle así radio ok
muy bien este de aquí es el radio vale
entonces todos estos puntos siempre
están a un radio de distancia del centro
bueno esa es la primer propiedad o la
primera cosa que nos interesa de los
círculos la segunda es saber qué tan
gordo son es decir cuál es la distancia
de un punto al que está exactamente del
lado opuesto por ejemplo podría medir
esto de acá esto de acá en la distancia
de éste a este de acá algo de este
estilo algo de este estilo o bien
podríamos medir la de este a este de acá
algo de este estilo pero lo que no se
vale para decir que tan gordo es es
medir digamos de acá para acá porque eso
no está midiendo todo verdad eso nada
más mide un cachito bueno pues resulta
que si medimos qué tan gordo es un
círculo si vamos de un punto al extremo
justo cruzamos por el centro vale y eso
aún
una recta a un segmento dentro de un
círculo que pase por el centro se le
conoce como un diámetro aquí le voy a
poner diámetro diámetro
y existe una relación muy sencilla entre
radio y diámetro porque como el diámetro
pasa justo por el centro entonces
consiste de dos radios este de acá y
este de acá de esta forma tenemos
nuestra primera relación importante en
los círculos el diámetro de un círculo
siempre es igual a dos veces dos veces
su radio muy bien entonces estas dos
propiedades son muy interesantes vamos a
la tercera la tercera es el perímetro
del círculo el perímetro esto de acá eso
también se le conoce como la longitud de
la circunferencia o en algunos casos
algunos autores lo manejan como la
circunferencia pero aquí le llamaré le
llamaremos el perímetro y justo es como
el perímetro usual imagínate que tomamos
nuestra cinta para medir
y vemos cuánto tenemos que recorrer para
darle toda la vuelta entonces eso va a
ser el perímetro déjame marcarlo por acá
y entonces si le damos toda la vuelta y
vemos cuánto mide cuánto mide a eso le
vamos a llamar el perímetro perímetro
perímetro ahora observa que tenemos una
relación muy sencilla entre el diámetro
y el radio así que con un poco de suerte
podemos encontrar una relación muy
sencilla entre el perímetro y el
diámetro o bien el perímetro y el radio
bueno vamos a explorar esto resulta que
las personas se hicieron esta esta
pregunta desde hace mucho tiempo atrás y
vieron más o menos lo siguiente
empezaron viendo que un círculo por
ejemplo tenía perímetro de más o menos
3.1 no de más o menos tres digamos o sea
más o menos 33.1 es más o menos tres
entonces dijeron es más o menos tres de
perímetro y le puse un diámetro de más o
menos uno vale entonces me dieron se
dieron cuenta de esto y encontraron
entonces
la razón lo voy a poner aquí la razón
la razón entre el perímetro
entre el perímetro y el perímetro
y el diámetro y el diámetro diámetro
diámetro era aproximadamente de 3 entre
1 y bueno si esto es más o menos 3 y
esto es más o menos 1 entonces a lo
mejor es razonable pensar que la razón
era 3 pero luego empezaron a ser mejores
mediciones se consiguieron mejores
cintas para medir y digamos que
encontraron por acá un círculo otro
círculo
voy a pintar lo más o menos así bueno lo
voy a hacer más chiquito y se dieron
cuenta que no se este círculo midiendo
tenía un perímetro aproximadamente el
perímetro era aproximadamente igual a
3.1 y el diámetro era aproximadamente
igual a 1 y dijeron chin entonces la
razón no es 13 es como más cercana a 3.1
y luego dijeron bueno pero esto será
cierto para todos los círculos y bueno
vieron no sé
imagínate que dibujaron otro círculo y
encontraron que el perímetro era más o
menos como 6.2 y el diámetro era más o
menos cómodos y entonces dijeron bueno
parece ser que las razones como 3.1 pero
después pues empezaron a construir
mejores y mejores cintas para medir y se
encontraron con que el número pues no
era 3.1 sino que era mucho más cercano a
este número súper especial que voy a
escribir
se dieron cuenta que la razón era
aproximadamente igual a igual a 3.14 159
y así sucesivamente y así sucesivamente
y encontraron este número así súper
místico cuyos dígitos no se repetían y
se dieron cuenta que no era un número
racional lo que eso quiere decir así que
le dieron un número un nombre especial
por supuesto que merecía un nombre
especial porque los círculos son
especiales y fundamentales como este
número resultó también tan fundamental
se le dio un nombre y el nombre que se
le dio a esta razón entre el perímetro y
el diámetro de un círculo fue que le voy
a poner por acá y sale esto de acá es
así en en español pero también se puede
utilizar la letra griega y vale entonces
este numerito se le conoce como pi y
justo está definido como la razón entre
el perímetro y el diámetro de una
circunferencia y vale aproximadamente
esto
este aquí es un número fascinante y
después en tu carrera matemática te vas
a dar cuenta que aparece por todas
partes aquí aparece en el círculo pero
después aparecen integrales y en
funciones trigonométricas y otras cosas
que ahorita aparecen espantosas pero que
después va a saber que están bien
bonitas vale bueno entonces la razón
entre el perímetro y el diámetro lo voy
a poner por acá la razón entre el
perímetro perímetro
y el diámetro perímetro / diámetro
diámetro es igual a pi es igual a pi y
lo vamos a escribir nada más así vale
bueno y estoy acá porque nos va a servir
como lo vamos a utilizar bueno pues si
sabemos que el perímetro entre el
diámetro es igual a ti entonces podemos
multiplicar por el diámetro de ambos
lados y obtener lo voy a poner en color
azul que el perímetro de una
circunferencia es igual a pi pi x el
diámetro x el diámetro y bueno como
podemos poner al diámetro en términos
del radio también podemos poner al
perímetro en términos del radio y para
hacer esto simplemente sustituimos esta
de aquí abajo el perímetro es igual a pi
por diámetro que es igual a pi
multiplicado por dos veces cr o bien lo
vas a haber escrito más frecuentemente
como dos veces
y por radio
muy bien con esta fórmula vamos a hacer
algunos ejemplos vale déjame bajar para
tener más despacio vamos a bajar por acá
y vamos a resolver algunos problemas
imaginemos que tenemos un círculo un
círculo ahí está y nos dicen que el
radio el radio es de tres metros tres
metros y a partir de esta información
queremos calcular el perímetro el
perímetro y el diámetro como le haríamos
bueno pues aquí ya tenemos la fórmula
para encontrar el perímetro en términos
del radio verdad nos dicen que el
perímetro el perímetro es igual a 22 por
pi
por el radio pero el radio en este caso
es 3 metros sería 2 por pi por 3 metros
y por lo tanto el perímetro es igual a 2
por 13 66 x pi y eso sería en metros
metros ahora y es un número verdad ya
vimos aquí arriba que pies un número que
es como 3.14 15 9 como 3.1 entonces
entonces esta expresión de acá todavía
se podría desarrollar si tuviéramos una
calculadora 6 es un número pi es un
número entonces podríamos hacer la
multiplicación de 6 por pi y nos daría
un número pero ahorita no nos interesa
mucho encontrar ese número porque como
pi sigue y sigue entonces este número
sigue y sigue entonces aunque si
podríamos hacerlo con una calculadora
muchas veces los matemáticos deciden que
es mejor idea simplemente poner aquí pi
y que esto sea la respuesta vale y lo
vamos a dejar así nuestro perímetro será
de 6.000 metros
6 metros vale bueno y ahora como le
haríamos para encontrar el diámetro
bueno pues para encontrar el diámetro
simplemente tendríamos que multiplicar
este radio por 2 lo voy a hacer a la
derecha
entonces el diámetro el diámetro es
igual a 2 veces el radio que es igual a
6 a 6 metros sale bueno entonces ahí
tenemos el perímetro y el diámetro otra
vez esto de aquí es un número de hecho
como pieza aproximadamente 3 entonces
este número es como 18 un poco más de 18
vale si quieres le pongo que es como
como 18 puntos y ese 8 quedó un poco feo
18 punto y está muy bien vamos a hacer
otro problema déjame trazar acá otra
circunferencia ahora vamos a pensar las
cosas al revés entonces aquí tenemos un
círculo la orilla del círculo es la
circunferencia entonces ahí tenemos un
círculo e imagínate que ahora lo que nos
dicen es que el perímetro el perímetro
es de 10 metros de 10 metros o sea
tomamos nuestra cinta para medir vemos
cuánto mide esto y nos dio exactamente
10 metros y que a partir de ahí queremos
determinar el diámetro el diámetro
bueno como le haríamos ahora déjame
subir para volver a ver la fórmula
usaríamos esta verdad el perímetro es
igual a pi por diámetro
entonces el perímetro ahora es 10 metros
entonces tendríamos que 10 metros 10
metros es igual a pi por diámetro y para
encontrar diámetro simplemente dividimos
entre pide a ambos lados acuérdate que
pienso el número sale entonces aquí se
cancela con esto y nos queda quede el
diámetro y es igual a 10 entre p entre
pi metros insisto como pienso número 10
entre pi también es un número como pies
3.14 10 entre pi también va a ser tres
punto y algo no lo puedo hacer
mentalmente pero bueno el diámetro sería
10 entre pi metros y si nos pidieran del
radio si nos pidieran el radio pues
simplemente hay que utilizar la fórmula
que dice que que dos veces el radio es
igual al diámetro haciendo la
sustitución con este valor que ya
tenemos de diámetro dos veces el radio
es igual
/ 10 / pi metros que se me quedó
horrible metros y dividiendo entre 2
tenemos que el radio es igual a un medio
de 10 / ep / pi metros podríamos dejarlo
así pero se puede simplificar verdad 10
entre 12 5
entonces nos quedaría 5 entre pi entre
pi metros muy bien entonces en realidad
estos ejercicios son son sencillos
aunque pi sea un número muy especial
pues en realidad de hacer cuentas o
hacer ejercicios es algo muy fácil lo
único que tenemos que recordar es que
hay que tratar a pi como si fuera un
número vale y es un número es muy
especial hay cientos de libros escritos
acerca de pi bueno a los fuerzo es una
exageración pero es muy especial tiene
propiedades muy interesantes pero
ahorita simplemente podemos meterlo a
esto de los círculos a través de estas
fórmulas vale bueno en el siguiente
vídeo platicaremos acerca del área de un
círculo